[Musik]
heute ist peter und den süchtigen stelle
für die noten der süchtige und für die
richtige womit auch jeder sucht
gestorben sind uns trotz erinnere mich
mit oeko tex anonymous kurz m&a ist die
zweitgrößte selbsthilfegruppe der welt
entstanden ist sie in den usa aus den
anonymen alkoholikern der größten
selbsthilfegruppe weltweit gibt es
70.000 m a meetings pro woche allein in
zürich finden täglich mehrere treffen
statt
einzige bedingung für die teilnahme ist
der wunsch mit drogen aufzuhören mit
drogen ist auch alkohol gemeint es ist
ein programm völlige abstinenz viele
meetings sind offen für angehörige
fachpersonen und für journalistinnen wie
mich
[Musik]
ich bin sehr frühe von drogen ewig sie
mit sunny und ich hatte es vor allem
also klar ist es abartig sie und fasst
und irgendwie spaß so aber im nachhinein
kann ich sage ich kann vor allem an
speziellen jungen und sichere maxi und
ich kann einfach arminia mit dem
reformvertrag und fachwissen findet weil
er noch nie was mich als süchtige sehr
schnell auszeichnet dass ich auch
erstmal kontrolle über müssen eifern
oder haben heiner niemann kannst ja
nicht sagt mache ich mir irgendwann habe
ich gemerkt dass das zogen nämlich
zerstört um ist aber zerstört und nicht
zurück gemacht wenn ich mit witz und
einer mini wert verloren und so ja
irgendwann eines den griff kriegen auf
zuhörer und zwar mit einer und mit einem
meetings so ein wichtiges auto nicht
dann begleitete dieses zeit mit honig 7
zoll touchscreen das im heim bin ich
hier mehr oder weniger ruiniert im
voraus wissen sagt geschlagen haben der
mann gesehen nicht an dass am ist
grafite meine stream beladen und das für
eine aushalten und das reine clean
aushalten
ich unglaublich schwer und war sich alle
kannten ist das konzept vor
darüber reden hilft ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar sie was das erbringen
[Musik]
schön zum dass sie ich bin manchmal
ihnen den zugang mit dem wissen dass ich
helfen teile bis mister anderes gefunden
die minister dass sie es anderes also
für das bin ich zu der erzgänge und
handeln wir medikament verschrieben und
einen plan aufstellen und habe ich
probiert so gut dass zahlt dann aber die
einzige verein der region erongo nötig
weil ich dass ich einfach katalogen
immer und das hat einfach nicht lange
schon immer wieder angefangen ich bin
relativ gut gefahren in eine klinik wir
nehmen austraten und ihr klient bleiben
und ich fand nie realisiert dass
irgendetwas in mir scheint die
vorschläge dass sie beim hauptproblem
sind ich sie dass er nicht das hat nicht
wie alt eine noch nicht realisiert
[Musik]
adrian ist seit acht jahren clean er ist
43 jahre alt und erfolgreicher
geschäftsmann
er nahm kokain und heroin
sich in den haupt sie zum konsum und
sich auch so ein mangel mäßiger kurve
nach ufa und emotional und vor allem
eine geschichte erinnert die schnelle
kurven aber noch nicht das ist ein
rückblick sind das 15 jährige ist wir
sind wir hätten nur einmal warum
schlingert und kommt nicht mehr
im büro sie nach einer kriminelle akte
zu machen also schon schon eine
unnatürliche spruch für den alten stil
und ich fand ein anderes objektive
mitarbeiter anleitung schafft mit
antenne des alten mini konnte dahinter
reihten sich ein
das ist nicht ohne sie hat eigentlich
dimensionen apropos schon längstens
nehmen denn auch nie lustig
sie ist wie christel jeder bereich vom
im leben nicht betroffen
[Musik]
auf stolze handy das auf fremde handys
überhaupt sehr schnell mit ihm über
großaufträge aus gemerkt dass wir da
dominik märkl mail abonnieren reporta
mini konnte hatten das gebäude eskaliert
merken dass du ihn zuverlässig und so
das ist eindeutig so dass in wenigen
jahren zu mir ist das auch als ich bin
einmal weniger worte und dabei war man
nicht mit drauf los das war einfach
weniger wurde aber alle durchgemacht
warum also soll beschäftigt und ich als
einfach süß gemacht aber wir sind sicher
haben höchst ich sie jetzt mal von deren
konstruktion und ich haben oder
vorgesprochen
aber es ist ganz konkret nimmst du
trugen also ich immer nein gesagt ist
auf 1 698 box der mechanismus vor ist
fatal die gemini sich besuchen
das ist das ist so stark weil das
lügenkonstrukt uhr womit er gab mit
einer schranke das ist das ist
überlebenswichtig in dem moment in dem
man das opus wind dann ein anderes ich
alles oder dann verliere ich die ganz
kontrolle behindert
nach seinem dritten einzug wurde adrian
vatter
die mutter des kindes war ebenfalls
drogensüchtig während der
schwangerschaft bekannt sie kontrolliert
mit atom und die geburt clean erlaubt
der sohn hat ein gradmesser von gsa die
neonatologie wenn sich einer
substituiert sich hat als erste mal
einen entzug machen
es ist extrem schwierig sie zum das zum
ssv team und akzeptieren und wisse ja
dass ich dass ich es ist für
schuldenschnitt dafür und ich einfach
offen von einem von einem konstrukt ich
alles gegangen hat das burgmeister sich
danach mit jede therapie institution und
dann schmeißen immer eine vorbei nicht
sehr stück fertig wurde
und dann hat er angefangen es ist ganz
ist wieder gefragt wo er hat nix hat
nicht es hat nicht sucht ich größer
nach vier kürzeren zügen macht adrian
eine siebenmonatige langzeittherapie
dort lernt er erkennen konzept wohl ich
gefahren bin ich natürlich totalen ihres
in berlin wurde aber - hat sich sie zum
alleinschuldigen bliebe das kann ich
schon und das ist tief verankert ich
glaube eine leistungs muster von flender
und ich fand ich kann wählen als sieger
vom platz kabel
ich fand der sieg müssen wir mehr fälle
zu ordnen und das ist ja danach zog sich
schon dass wir live willst dich wirklich
ein wert kommt aber das ist ja nie
allein worden bin dass eine stadt da
landet sie ich glaube ich noch volk sie
wäre stark wir sind halt viel mit
klienten taxi und sind dabei ist
eigentlich der aufmachung nehmen
freiwillig wurden also das ist das
stimmt jetzt sind wir gerecht verliehen
die meist konsumierte droge bei n/a ist
alkohol gefolgt von cannabis und kokain
so ist es auch in der gesellschaft
allgemein
die rückfallquote eines drogensüchtigen
liegt bei über 90 prozent
und trotzdem suchen immer mehr menschen
in den räumen von n a nachhilfe oder
wird sich eine neue programmstruktur
rückfall kommen wir zum zweiten der
orange hatte brent angebot sagt die star
clipper dritter letzte woche zwischen
einem jahr und 18
mehr ist über zwei jahren für einen
fußballer aber nicht was und die sind
schon alle die den drogen stand meistens
nachts wo irgendwo im nirgendwo liegen
wir sandra ist 34 jahre alt seit sieben
monaten lebt sie drogenfrei sie hat
einen jüngeren bruder
ihre eltern sind seit 40 jahren
glücklich verheiratet
sie sagt dir kindheit sei behütet
gewesen
trotzdem beginnt sie früh in ihrer
jugend exzessiv alkohol zu trinken
aufmerksamkeit eher weniger aktivität
ich bin immer mit voller lieder software
bis in die nacht
dann habe ich das alles machen und ich
möchte gern gemacht und dann nicht dass
alles gesehen
eine postini kaufte mir im bett ist
norton wir zum aufputschen weg machen
was er immer und ich kann aber wieder
angriffe aus dem netz kokoity
ich bin jemand weiß gehüllt oder am
anfang hätte das positive effekt für
mich doch lieber wieder mit einer sitzt
zwar wach halten und aufputsch das hätte
ich habe innerlich wir ruhiger gemacht
es raus im oktober der ober herrschten
bauern sehen wie schwer sich lehre nicht
dass ich so viel lärm so viel blut und
so anstrengend und mit dem koks ist das
sortiert xii sie schicken mir sich dann
alles um das budget meiner canal + ich
habe das gefühl wohl eher nicht so rosig
gemüsebeet jahre hindurch einfach immer
gesteigert hat das hat es mir knopf
[Musik]
depression erkrankt oder eine offshore
gesellschaft will althaus voll mit lage
nicht der dow ab das wäre jetzt will sie
das stimmige - haltbar oder betrag
wachsen und du darfst das ist einige
oder halt einfach das gefühl foto
unmittelbarkeit vor allem und dann auch
gesundheitlich hat mit diesem system ein
arsch oder kann
ich bin wahnsinnig oft krank sie für
michael kroker der großteil der technik
merkt dass wir das ist eigentlich
schmerzen haben das kokain das bedeutet
und das ist eine psychische und
körperliche spirale nach einem
gescheiterten selbst entzug bei ihren
eltern geht sie in eine klinik
dort stellt sich die nav sandra fühlt
sich angesprochen
seither besucht sie fast täglich ein
meeting
[Musik]
sieht regelmäßige meetings gang sich
täglich meetings besucher an ich glaube
diese für andere zurück macht kann lernt
ehrlich sie ich muss nämlich das ehrlich
sie ich darf sagen was ich vielleicht
das sage was ich danken und das ist
sicher bis 15 steigen eine acht jahre
lange zeit was ich danke ich kann
nämlich keine rede ich habe mich schwer
die mir selber und ist einfach schön zu
wenig sehe wie alle sich auch für andere
die der familie ich mein verhältnis zum
im money wird wieder schön sind
ausständig miteinander und ich bin jetzt
am ersten schritt und ich bald teile und
dafür bin ich unheimlich dankbar
geschlossen basiert auf einem zwölf
schritte programm an diesen zwölf
schritten arbeiten die mitglieder
außerhalb der meetings
hier sind die schritte die unsere
genesung ermöglicht haben erste wir
geben zu dass wir unsere sucht gegenüber
machtlos waren und unser leben nicht
mehr meistern konnten dritte treffen
eine entscheidung unseren willen und
unser leben der fürsorge gottes sowie
nieren verstanden zu vertragen
8 wir machten eine liste aller personen
denen wir schaden zugefügt hatten und
wurden bereiten bei allen wieder
gutzumachen zwölfter nachdem ihr als
ergeben ist dieser schritt ein
spirituelles erwachen erlebt hatten
versuchten wir diese botschaft an andere
süchtige weiterzugeben und unser
tägliches leben nach diesen prinzipien
auszurichten
dies alles hört sich wie eine riesige
aufgabe an und wir können die sicherlich
nicht auf einmal bewältigen
wir wurden schließlich auch nicht in
einem tag süchtig deshalb heißt es
geduld literatur kaputt treten
spirituell religiöse bedeuten oder dass
es irgendwie bestimmt die wohl
stellichte vorgeht wie der gosse sie und
ich mein wort kontur aber unter höhe für
die macht ab 57 prozent steht umschrieb
es rund drei meter zur seite
so wie wir ihn verstehen dh dass ich
wirklich ganz persönlich wie im jahr
klarheit das konklave sie begrüßen liegt
aber ich glaube es hängt mit letzte so
herkömmlicher glaubens bilder nicht viel
am hut
herr oder was mit sponsor in heime gern
als beispiel bringt das wenn die
gemeinschaftlich in den usa und die zwei
kräfte im iran und das sind die
glaubensgemeinschaft christlich oder
muslimisch fragt also zwei ganz
unterschiedliche sachen beiden
funktioniert das programm
ein erfahrenere senna mitglied eines
sogenannte sponsoring bietet
unterstützung auch bei der umsetzung der
zwölf schritte
[Musik]
schritt 1 die krankheit sucht
was bedeutet die krankheit sucht für
mich sucht bedeutet für mich einsamkeit
hoffnungslosigkeit dunkelheit zwar teils
kreis was ist der unterschied zu unserer
therapie wo die psychologin aber die ahv
wie fundiert wenn ich mal rein und nach
wie vor therapie und das ist auch das
hilft mir auch oder zara hat ganz andere
herangehensweise der mann sie ist selbst
betroffen von dem modell das heißt sie
haben innerhalb vermied ihre erfahrungen
und sich vermischen umsetzbar wäre
emirates will für den 24
ich bin ja halt einfach jeden tag
eigentlich in den anderen damit den
uralt holt sie das mit sehr viel aufwand
betrieben und flaschen entsorgen und so
eine frau wirklich in not ist denn
bietet sie aber allen seiten ich kann
das problem und sie teils und ihre hilft
den habe ich einfach nur klare ruhige
stimme verlost
also ich muss gar nicht so viel spaß
machen dann bin ich da
ich wohne seit knapp zwei jahren
unterhält megageil gefunden und ich
halte da aber langstrasse hundertschaft
da man unterwegs bin und jetzt bin ich
hier betonte nordisch sandra arbeitet im
kulturbereich und am wochenende hinter
der bar eines klubs seit sie keine
drogen mehr nimmt hat sie den job hinter
der bar aufgegeben
ja das sind sie nicht platzen dort dank
des nah und ich mein fehlverhalten im
netz gemacht aber es ist wirklich an die
angst nehmen
also nochmal wir euch die angst weil ich
einfach weiß wenn ich mitbringen so dort
machen und macht dann muss ich hier mit
der therme und dass ich einfach nur der
mit seinen schönsten die sucht
beeinflusst alle bereiche ihres lebens
[Musik]
gelitten hat vor allem die beziehung zu
ihrem bruder als sie noch drohen nahm
hatten sie zusammen gewohnt
er hat es aber nicht mehr ausgehalten
und ist ausgezogen thema wohn ich bin
immer noch diskutieren ich bin auch eine
zahl bei drinnen und ich kann mich nicht
so ganz denn ihr versetzen und darum ist
es wirklich so ich hätte lieber mit dir
über andere dinge also ist mit über das
thema weiter die haben mir dabei hofft
jetzt vor dem 3
das das wir mal zur sprache und was und
die features des mega wertvolles know
wie ich muss nur zeigen weiß dass alles
gut ist in klien ich mache das sollte
ich glaube sie spürt dass mir gesprochen
will ich wieder die ganze zeit auf der
matratze
[Musik]
sandra ist zwar klein und trotzdem die
drogen sind noch sehr präsent
dank eindruck dass aber es ist nicht so
der zwang das gefühl ich muss jetzt
tragen dass ich wirklich schon viel
besser wurde
die große mehrheit der menschen
konsumiert drogen auf unproblematische
art rund ein viertel jener die drogen
nehmen hat probleme und diese probleme
sind sehr heftig ärzte sind meist die
erste anlaufstelle eines drogensüchtigen
menschen während die im ausland dna oft
ins therapieprogramm von kliniken
integriert ist lässt sich in der schweiz
kaum eine klinik finden die das tut wäre
es an den ärzten die nr bekannter zu
machen
die klinik im hause stellt der nr zwar
einen raum zur verfügung aber ein
obligatorischer teil der therapie ist
das n a meeting nicht
der kontakt ist persönlich betroffen
sein
ja wir haben über den professionellen
blick wir sind selber nicht betroffen
und das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht
geben auch das was an
ja weil er persönlicher bindung
natürlich versucht mir der therapie eine
bindung zu machen aber sie in der regel
die bindung laden anfangen da gibt es
bestimmt das programm was läuft und dann
hat sie oft auch mit am ende und bei
denen es zum beispiel die seine
persönliche bindung die deutlich mehr
anbietet auf mehr was eigentlich auf
lebenslange erstmal ausgelegt ist und
das können wir überhaupt nicht auch die
verfügbarkeit jederzeit anrufen zu
können wir haben also öffnungszeiten da
unsere notfall prozent der rest ist
könne somit nicht anbieten auch knapp
vier weitere bereiche umfasst wir
schauen doch eher so dass funktionale
verhaltensmuster soziale reintegration
sozialpsychiatrische themen aber jetzt
nicht freundschaft und und lebensglück
für mich wie frage der autonomie anteil
oder wie viel ich dann an süchtige
niederlage
die punkte oder in stationäre
institution grund zum woche eine selber
entscheide was für dich dein was ist ein
gut für mich ich weiß was ich gesund ich
bin froh bin ich gewiss nie bereits um
im glück gezwungen wurde
weil ich jetzt alleine gefunden und sie
sind aber nicht erschienen sind da nicht
zu sagen wir zwingen wird zwingen die
leute sondern die autonomie des selber
entscheiden das abwägen das vorbereiten
das ist uns eigentlich ganz wichtig dass
das beim patienten ist nicht was mir das
machen die lobeck vom zentrum für
suchtmedizin in zürich sieht den
abstinenz ansatz der enr kritisch also
entweder auf finnland oder südkorea 60
übertrieben gesagt wo dann verliert das
netz stehen wo doch sich überlegen ob
sie dann wieder kontrolliert konsumieren
weniger konsumieren
die fühlen sich minderwertig oder mit
deiner vorgaben entsprechen und das ist
dann hinter kontraproduktiven effekt
also ich glaube dir der kranken ist von
der materie untersucht ob das dass es
eben aus holz für alle gibt
sind sie schon mal ein meeting sie ich
persönlich bin ire sieht das muss ich
unbedingt sehen sie das ist so dir die
experte rolle wo man gestrickt und um
nichts weniger
das muss ich sagen muss ich sagen dass
die abstinenz als nicht zeitgemäß
die fachwelt stört sich an diesem
einseitigen ansatz doch kennen die ärzte
dna überhaupt es lässt sich praktisch
kein arzt finden der je an einem meeting
war
ich frage mich wäre es nicht sinnvoll
die n a mehr ins therapieangebot
einzubinden
oder ist es tatsächlich ein programm für
wenige andere seidenberg bekannter als
platzspitz arzt hat sich auf schwer
süchtige spezialisiert wie so dass ich
mich heute für die interessierten sich
für die klientel wobei mir im
fortbestand wenn ich war meistens carbon
green stimmt wirklich dringend hilfe
braucht dann einfach nicht das mittel
sie wo zielführende seidenberg
behandelte vor allem ob die züchtige
also menschen die heroin konsumierte
also ich denke das kommt schon viele
gute hilfe
opioide panisch stars oder häufig
nottwil ein opioid abstinenz tränkt der
innere größere vor ihnen als andere auf
die substitution hat also sprich
methadon hat den ruf in rotterdam an
puppen oder das ist nicht mein abschied
am tisch
plötzlich wieder zurück fällig werden
dann die jetzt gefährlich will dann hat
er denn jemand mehr hat die orient und
oliver herunter und ich spiele gerne auf
und sich sagt sie enttäuscht und chance
dass seine tollität chance dass dann
ungefährlicher konsumiert spricht
es spritzt und vielleicht spritzt
braucht die nato braucht und sowie der
tätige situationen sind dann und dann
passiert das worauf die seite oder sogar
dort zu drucken
die liebschaften auch finanzwerte mit
dna das opioid 60 getrennt sagt sie das
sind alles krusty einzelfall
ich denke wichtig ist dass man zwei
jahren ohne dass man länger läuft und
ich bin heute joggt oder halbtrocken
doktor gehört sie mir gesagt dass ich an
ganz langen flur geht uns gibt der
wissenschaftler untersuchen warum züge
hat man wirklich keine bewiesen dass sie
für jüngst prozent
du hast du fördern das muss man zur
kenntnis dass man wirklich zu kennen
diesen 11 1% 5 irgendwann wieder und
wieder fangen ganz gefährliche situation
und auf die ziele mit 54 5 prozent
aber es ist sehr schade dass es
langfristig klingt und muslime frage zu
welchem preis
adrian der heroin nahm ist bereit dieses
risiko einzugehen
im kontrollierten drogen programm zu
bleiben kam für ihn nicht in frage
strato mit stick morgen und ich bin auf
dem parkplatz standen die metropole und
spiele ich gerne ausgelegt 78 eine drei
wochen
wie genau so verlor videothek stande die
von kwanika was mich erwartet und und
automatische sucht luckow und kann die
spirale von könig stationieren rückfall
kam als nicht einmal suchtdruck k wieder
einmal musste patient und kind längst
die freiheit droht wieder alles
abzudecken und ich bin wirklich sehr
und gefühlt jeder bedienen ist und ich
finde es sehr schwierig mich selber als
die letzten zwei tage mit
verhaltensweise von mir selber
konfrontiert worden bin weil ich ja
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr selbst das ist
das ist wirklich für mich der schlüssel
nicht gefunden haben und vergleich sehr
sehr dankbar bin
wenn man das denn unser trainingslager
das geradezu kurzen miterlebt
eine siebenjährige bin ich aus russlands
rocco und dem bus gestanden und er hat
eine frau in grand blanc
das ist ein aktiv süchtig sie und die
hat hinter dem rücken der stinkefinger
zeigen unser super liga groß sie
erfahrene genesen ist ausgestreckt die
frau im schlaf mit gepackten
zusammenstöße und gesagt mit nienburg
macht das nicht
und der libor bisschen nervig standen
hat mich komplett entsetzt angeordnet
und ich hatte ausgemacht wo sie schon
das weiß ich dass kann ich heute nicht
ausgemacht und dass ich habe mich mit
dem siebenjährigen entschuldigen für
miss russia für ein foul die energie wo
nicht reagiert haben adrians sohn henry
war im alter von zweieinhalb bis vier im
kinderheim oswald grünen felder war
damals der leiter von henrys wohngruppe
[Musik]
und dann doch spielt oder zum beispiel
tage mit lissabon ein großes boot das
ich fernsehe ecke sie unter anderem ist
er im fernsehen ist ziemlich darin
bestehen ob er immer auf deiner seite
ich mich sind immer schlafen im
kinderheim inselhof können kinder
bleiben bis sie neun jahre alt sind
kinder aus belasteten familien
häufig spielen drogen eine rolle papi
der therapie sense oder und da war pelé
hat ja und hat ja schaffen und eine
razzia um ist mami ich die therapie xiii
der bin ich halt immer wie musik und wie
der anderen mittags irgendwann spaß
kommt ein bisschen bis ich habe mir papi
und mami hals immer mich erinnere ich an
ihnen diese lebhafter erinnerung und was
mir blieben ist bei mir 70 account
während andere monate standort 70 wunder
wo man nur geht das erste ereignis
gemacht hat so das erste tor sieht sich
das craften ältere die hand sie trennt
erlebt wie gut sie das ersten tag machte
die situation im workflow angeht weil es
dauert und man sich und dann hätte so
für tag genau seit wie lange das ritz
abstimmen
und das hat mir immer große das hätten
wir immer ist ein großer druck gemacht
ich morgens oder die ministerin sieht es
mir wichtig sie und zeigen was das
können absprechen aber vor allem die oft
keine fußball-fans schwierig funde zwölf
personen lag da und die machtlosigkeit
der permanent ausgesetzt sie also es ist
in obhut sind selten einfach mit
mittlerweile herrscht und
nichtsdestotrotz einig dass man hier
schafft das mir irgendwie das mitten im
inselhof wenn ich einfach nie erlebt
dass ich es gefunden es wird gab es
geschafft und ich warne aber davor
vorherigen institutionen die erfahrungen
gemacht
und das hatte bis extrem befreien score
henrys mutter ist immer noch im
kontrollierten drogen programm
mit hilfe seiner eigenen mutter kümmert
sich adrian um henry obwohl adrian seit
acht jahren clean ist ist auch er nicht
sicher davor wieder drogen zu nehmen
die drogensucht fesselt süchtige ein
leben lang dreimal pro woche geht adrian
in 1 a meeting place erster stelle stand
das ist bisweilen ich früher in der show
kehrt an schmecken ist wie wir das
machen und mit klage sogar so dass das
wohl nicht übermäßig stelle wird erst
das eben später für ihre das heißt mit
soul funk nach minergie sich viel erlebt
hat
wissen sie etwas umgestellt sieht um
folgen sind verheerend ist im heimkino
und wichtigste so dass der mini mini
arbeitsamt classicdepot anspruch fehlt
sieht echt super sturm zu verdauen muss
ich sagen so haben wir mit dem grund
will kann mitmachen
ich glaube es ist wirklich nicht einfach
nur vorstellen aber ich bin sehr stolz
auf das man erreicht hat merkt das haben
wir jetzt sind wenn er bedeutet dann ist
er da und hilft oder 4000 er selber mit
sich meine sie das sehr beeindruckend
es ist müßig zu sagen was wer wann hause
also ich will ich da auf dem unter der
werke kurzarbeit
ich glaube einfach niemals so
tiefgründig ja und ich hätte das nicht
gefunden
meine ich nicht angefangen drogen das
ist mir bewusst
ich kann wirklich vermisse der
unglaubliche preis zahle zu den zugang
verhindert somit programmiert ausgeht
und ich fit bin
[Applaus]
körperlich geistig seelisch bin ich am
[Musik]
kreis groß gerau und habe seitdem rollt
gelost rocksound bin ich wirklich wollte
könnte bezweifelt sie das irische
fernsehen oft unter dem eindruck der
integration was machst du da und machte
der derbe sprüche zum allerdings hat ja
ich mache mache ich drucke mit drogen
ihnen und und machten daraus ein tier
wenn die käuferin aber wenn du dich das
ist ja nicht ich weiß nicht wen ich muss
stehen
[Musik]
ich bin das kind das sie vor sechs
kinder hatte für halbjahr
wenn ich an meine kindheit zurückdenken
das ist sehr sehr streng sie also ein
handwerklich mehr bürstenschnitt machen
als ich gefragt wurde
zwei meter schnitt denn erzogen wurde
sind wir mit schlag also empfiehlt der
fraktion und im ersten zu locken wenn
wir die brühe trübe schlager wurde sind
ist eingeschlagen wurde dann wirklich
eines häftlings schnitten einfach nur
mit der hand ins gesicht und gürtel und
teppichklopfern ganze programm und so
und so sehen es ist schon sehr dass ich
sie an und streng und redet sie so und
denn fertig bin back stage of classic
mini motor stieg sie depressiv aber so
schlaftabletten und und brot wie drink
von der morgan früheren sich das bett
geht und das ist auch das motto wenig
fürchtet die hand alle irgendwie der
bankkunde und warum dass es bei mir so
ich dir wurden sowie meer aus weißen
haus erklärt das geht gar nicht darum
später gar nicht jetzt groß schult sowie
sieger meine eltern machen das bringt
mich ja gar nicht weiter oder aber es
ist einfach so auf die jetzige position
aus dem sack ich bin ich wahrscheinlich
sehr sensibel sind sie
[Musik]
fast 20 jahre lang nahm roman drogen
alle möglichen drogen
seit 24 jahren ist aktiv
letztes jahr hatte ich ständig und der
wird tatsächlich wo der letzte grund
wurde ist dass ich genau identisch sind
verloren sieben ins ziel und ich bin ich
auch blödsinn in den tag und dann habt
ihr mit seite durchaus verstehen teile
der hunde zahl habe versagt
packt unterkühlt mit mir der
autorenkreis leide dann wenn überhaupt
einigen und betrieben hat enthüllt und
bin verloren morgen bin ich bin den
romanen spielsüchtige die 415 ist es
merklich oder die zeit und den hätte
mich wieder mal mit ganzen sack voll
klamotten ab schreibt also mega thürig
leider für müssten die zange und handy
retten das irgendwie raus präsentiert im
zimmer und nach dem schloss hat
irgendwie die tochter zwei so ganz wenig
boden verlieren oder vor uns andere
nicht oder
und ich hätte das nie so gehrke
und dann habe ich schicke dir denn
wirklich al wahda mittagstisch so machen
witze darüber gemacht was die
diesjährige heute für decken und war es
nicht so dass der gruppendruck oder was
cool ist und was nicht
am plötzlichen genau bei und ich möchte
die referentin schmerzen ist und
plötzlich ist mir alles ein wenig merkt
mein vater hat das einmal gemacht
beschreiben damit so zügig und hat sich
immer klar wurde hey super irgendwie die
das sind irgendwas zur verwandtschaft wo
mega felssturz hand klamotten oder und
meine tochter hat updike seit jetzt
einfach gesagt aus wort und das wort und
ich bin ich das mit jedem üben er wurde
das dass sie nicht mit läuferisch und
dass ich schon heiß erkennen oder muss
damit die rede
es tut mir leid
[Musik]
was ich die bosse für eine realistisch
beschrieben
er macht immer sehr viel spaß so lustig
so unterstrich dass die bildungsstätte
seine ehefrau und die kinder wissen von
seiner vergangenheit
das passiert ja und das ist nur eines
wichtig für mich
geburtstag oder das hätte für mich oder
bis vor einem halben jahr hatte roman
noch hepatitis c eine leberkrankheit
vermutlich verursacht durch verschmutzt
der nadeln
1 abstinenz leben war für ihn anfangs
unvorstellbar ich muss zwischen drei und
sechs männer zwischen ihr und druck
bringe und den hv mit weil mit welcher
substanz und wenn ihr den das im griff
hat inkontinenz egal ab und sorge dass
auch lustig das ist der plan
sie hatten im verlauf für die erste
portion von ihm klinsi soviel luxe die
meetings in horhausen dem ziel
geschlossen haben
ich schreibe mir total von rücker sich
vom ersten moment total das zu ihnen da
haben und übernahm zehnte fünfzehnter
mensch immer genau die geschäfte 20 grad
und harnik wird worum es als bei mir
anders sieht
und irgendwann haben ja mit mehr teil
des jetzt gab zum erstaunen habe dass
ich nicht irgendwie verloren eine
negative erfahrung muss man auch
besonders profitieren von den
erfahrungen aber ins negative zu ende
war vom hang müsse den vorbereitet was
die so sagen und damit bezieht dann
plötzlich vor der frage ich mache ich
spüre dass das kühlen
das wirkt ist gesteht ich weiß noch
nicht genau was und ich fange einfach an
sage ich bin nicht süchtig
der spruch mit dem namen und ich bin
süchtig wie wichtig ist ein total
komisch für oder haben jetzt das nicht
kennt
es geht ein rauher okay jetzt schwarz
der mensch und gleichzeitig ist eine
erinnerung daran dass ich einfach
süchtig bin und entscheide treffen habe
nicht mir wenn ich an schnitt mit
traumjob mit 32 warum man zwar
drogenfrei aber auch iv rentner ohne
ausbildung
er schloss seiner schreinerlehre mit
berufsmatura ab und schaffte den
einstieg in einen sozialen beruf dass
hier was seine erste arbeitsstelle
[Musik]
ich weiß dass mir oft mit rinder wenn es
schwierige situationen herr mir gespräch
mit der kinder geführt dass es so das
was am wm-ende stabil blieb ist und das
hat auch wirklich gut funktioniert so
die zwei sieger und der frauenmode
eingeschätzt hat das ist wirklich
richtig glück sie haben uns heute in der
knechtschaft haben das ist ja
grundsätzlich gut mit menschen und sehr
gut verstehen sie lokal paule und durch
der wunsch entstanden dass ich bin
einigen die witterung und den bereichen
ausbildung machen hat sich ziemlich klar
aufzeigt dass das wirklich etwas ist was
dir spaß macht freut macht und was auch
funktioniert mit
[Musik]
auch nach 24 jahren ohne drogen geht
roman einmal in der woche in einem
meeting einfach im raum von zehn minuten
arbeit und zum meer und um zulässige wir
dass ich dem meeting ende setzen und an
klar ich muss halt wissen nicht dass das
das sich andere das funktioniert einfach
nicht
das wird sogar den
[Musik]
ich stehe hier vor sich jemals wieder
drogen nein das ist ja nicht die ganz
viele wie spiel mir erster sponsor noch
15 jahre intensive zur kritik von der
marwitz 32 management rängen sportes
gestartet und ich kenne mich selber oder
ich weiß wenn ich funktioniere das habe
ich die ganz verschiedene falter vom vom
laderaum von der fanatische erfahrung
gemacht dass ich habe wirklich sondern
sondern seine struktur in ihr kleid das
wird die drogensucht ist eine last die
süchtige ein leben lang tragen müssen
sie kann zwar leichter werden ganz weg
geht sie nie
[Musik]
warum
[Applaus]
[Musik]